I walk in this morning Ronnie says to me
hey did you hear JD's news he didn't
have to say it I said what JD get
engaged he goes yes
I go oh how did you know I figured you
called nurani I understand that he says
to me no JD announced his engagement on
Twitter and for a split second I was
happy for him and then it turned to just
outright anger I said to myself you know
here's a [ __ ] guy he don't even know
by the way how much money do you make
from Twitter uh zero okay how much money
without giving him figures like how do
you pay your rent and how do you pay
your bills and all that stuff where do
you pay where do you who signs you
attack this this what isn't the name of
this company that Sirius satellite radio
sirius XM not serious serious XM yeah
cerise L AM serious LA maybe you work
for Sirius la sharika voila so in other
words doesn't it occur to you to say
okay I want to make the announcement
that I got engaged maybe I'll do it on
the show if since I'm going public with
this information what process do you go
through and then what did she say to
yourself when you show the ring the
engagement ring hey I'll put it on
Howard Stern comm and then I'll direct
everyone to the website because that's
where we traffic our stuff yes
[ __ ] ever do for you do everything
what do they do for you hold on did they
help you get a fiance they help you get
did they help you pay your bills you
think this is my show this is your show
to that I always think before I act I
always go hmm Twitter pay my bills or
the Sirius XM pay my bill I did hold on
did I mention one thing what I would say
that again I'm trying to follow the law
no I the the logic was with putting it
on Twitter
yeah my girlfriend is very into social
media yeah friends with a lot of people
here oh yeah so I felt it would be weird
if she announced it because she was she
was going to wait a second hold on
well where does she think you're getting
paid from she don't know you're in
business yeah this is how our lively lit
our life's blood
this is she doesn't know that you better
get her on the [ __ ] team
she's very mighty in here not everyone
hate me
no no but am I in this alone No
in other words really am I the only one
who really sits down and thinks about
that your show is everything hold on
explain it to me because I don't
understand I also felt yeah I would tell
you know what happened or whatever on
the show I didn't say anything about how
the engagement happened or if it wasn't
for me all right
you'd be a virgin right yeah it's true
did you get any [ __ ] before the show
tell the truth now no no your dick had
never even seen the light of day
maybe maybe you should work for cousin
Brucie he doesn't give up
twitter twitter you got to get paid from
twitter why work for me I'm an [ __ ] I
tell you what hat what I mean why would
you announce it on Twitter oh and by the
way who does he thank for the engagement
ring Steven singer which okay fine but
how does he get oh yeah how'd you get to
Steven singer through Ronnie how do I
get the Stephen singer you [ __ ] guys
don't have a clue okay I'm stupid
I could thank you personally ah yeah
yeah after the fact so big deal you're
getting married I heard everyone heard
about it or a sucker
how would you sucker Howard's a sucker
thank you thank you for playing that
Fred Irie man I'm a sucker I'm stupid I
mean I was happy for you for about a
second until I realized I go why would
JD not make the announcement here
because Twitter it's all about Twitter
and what Twitter needs Howard's a sucker
right who says that because I want to
thank this ow
so yeah thank you so Howard's a sucker
your loyalty is to Twitter not to me in
this show not that that is that's a
little unfair but okay in this place
there are some truth but I also felt
would drive excitement into by the way
JD will be receiving fifty percent of
his paycheck from Facebook and 50% of
the paycheck from Twitter
I actually just say I just changed the
relationship status and that that did
that put it up there is Facebook and
Twitter am I correct
no okay that sure seems that is a very
incorrect and believe me believe me I
don't want to say it I'm sure
[ __ ] it fiance you know what they do
Howard this is what happens they get a
life ya know it's not that they hate you
I'm gonna keep this for myself yeah yeah
this is from my Twitter followers I'm
starting my own thing well don't get mad
at Twitter Twitter doesn't do anything
it's just sitting there no no no waiting
for all the people you love to turn on
yeah right
JD's got his own little his own little
fiefdom on Twitter it's so stupid it's
such a shallow thing it is such moronic
thinking you getting engaged we've
followed you getting the girlfriend and
webcam girls and all this history the
culmination would be to announce it here
on the year if you're gonna go public
with it Howard's a sucker Howard's a
sucker that's the point and Howard I am
I am a sucker you can tell JD said
Howard is a sucker repeat me no say
Howard is it start Howard is the sucker
thank you thank you for saying it out
loud you know why not just kick me in
the balls why why why do the
psychological torture now if you think
I'm being rough on you you should feel
how rough I am on myself because I blame
myself for this yeah I'm you didn't know
I must have done something wrong to not
get loyalty from JD I've done something
wrong the first thing he would have said
is honey when he was talking to
offensive don't don't put this on
Facebook I want to say it on the air
this is where we make our living this is
how we're gonna pave if we have kids one
day they want to tell Howard on the air
yeah and it'll be good Radio Howard is
the sucker thank you thank you for
saying that
Howard is the sucker say it again hit me
with the hardest times in a row Howard
is the sucker yes Howard is the sucker
yes Howard is the sucker yes Howard is
the sucker yes I am a sucker Howard is a
sucker
mater word show JD's right huh honey
he's called you honey well you are my
honey there you go what do you think of
that
don't my right am I wrong JD I don't
want to you know I don't want to piss
all over right but same you're not
you're wrong you're not the only one
around here by the way doing this I want
you to do me one file awed and thinking
odd thing yeah you didn't think I want
you to do me one favor and I only ask
one thing
okay yes would you go to your Twitter
account now and just tweet out I hate my
boss please please I'm asking as a favor
please tweet that for an hour
no I want to see that on your account No
right Robin I only ask one favor get out
do I ask you a lot of favor I want it I
want Howard is a sucker how's that
sucker I will delete my Twitter before
that no don't delete it it's all right
I'm a [ __ ] I see I see the way you
mumble good morning in the morning Robin
try to think of the show not me
think of the show the next time please
am i right am I wrong
Yeah right all right all right fair
enough look let's never talk of this
again yeah Matt oh boy